[Musique]
donc ce serait ce bâtiment ici
serait ce site devrait être juste ici
et nous avons même un numéro Stingo oh d'accord
oh regarde là je vois rouge bleu rouge
puissant es-tu en haut ou est-ce assis
entre pause Poséidon c'est un gros  étape
pour Jill Kimmy ouais
ouais merci oh salut Jill
je suis Eugene ses amis d'un autre Canada
oh nous voulions en fait rencontrer
quelqu'un bien je voulais juste vous présenter
prenez une pharmacie pour moi je voudrais
vous présenter Jim incroyable pourquoi  est-ce
que vous n'acceptiez pas d'
interview et que vous nous demandiez de le
faire ou pourquoi Jim ne peut-il pas parler à une
personne réelle quand il essaie de vous joindre,
mais pourquoi d'accord si nous éteignons les
caméras êtes-vous  va répondre à nos
questions de manière appropriée,
alors quand vous a-t-elle dit là
-bas parce que nous avons dû arrêter d'enregistrer à un
moment donné, en ce qui concerne ce qu'elle m'a dit,
je pourrais contacter nos journalistes
et ils auraient la discussion avec moi
parce que j'étais  Je te signalais essentiellement